This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Here's something you probably didn't know about Mumbai, India. There are about 55 acres of dense, overgrown forest right downtown. In one of the most populous cities in the world, this is a place where peacocks roam freely. A place that seems to peel back centuries. This forest is protected by a religious community. It has survived undeveloped in the middle of this gargantuan city. Importantly, it's also home to an ancient tradition that's in crisis.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。关于印度孟买，有一件事你可能不知道。在市中心，有一片约55英亩茂密且杂草丛生的森林。在世界上人口最稠密的城市之一，这里竟是孔雀自由漫步的地方。这个地方仿佛让人穿越回了几个世纪前。这片森林由一个宗教团体保护着。它在这座庞大的城市中心得以幸存，未被开发。重要的是，它也是一个正处于危机中的古老传统的家园。
One of our producers, Lashma Dawn, traveled there in September. I turned off a busy road to get here, stepped through a large iron archway and up a small hill. The monsoon's long gone, but the air still feels heavy with moisture. Behind me, tall buildings shimmer in a haze of pollution. And up ahead, I see a sprawling expanse of green. This forest is called Dungarwadi. As you step in from the harsh sunlight and road outside, you just step into an extremely quiet place. This is Rashnit Bhardewala, someone who grew up in Mumbai
我们的制片人之一拉什玛·道恩（Lashma Dawn）九月份去了那里。我从一条繁忙的马路拐进这里，穿过一个巨大的铁拱门，走上一座小山。季风早已过去，但空气中依然弥漫着潮湿的重感。在我身后，高楼大厦在雾霾中闪烁。而在前方，我看到了一片广阔的绿色。这片森林被称为Dungarwadi。当你从外面刺眼的阳光和马路走进这里，你就进入了一个极其安静的地方。这是拉什尼·巴德瓦拉（Rashnit Bhardewala），一个在孟买长大的人，
and knows this place intimately. You can hear the dry leaves rustling below your footsteps. The forest is dark and deep. There are different trees in bloom, wild banana, mango, jackfruit, tamarind. I saw one whole tree just covered with fruit bats, tittering away. The vegetation here is dense. It's so thick, you've got to bend, you've got to see where you're stepping. But there's a certain point in this forest beyond which almost no one
并且对这个地方非常了解。你可以听到脚下干枯的树叶沙沙作响。森林又黑又深。有各种各样的树木在开花，野香蕉、芒果、菠萝蜜、罗望子。我看到整棵树上都挂满了果蝠，叽叽喳喳地叫着。这里的植被很茂密。它太厚了，你必须弯下腰，必须看清你踩在哪里。但在这片森林里有一个特定的点，超过这个点几乎没有人
can step. Not Rashne, and certainly not me. Only special caretakers of these grounds can go any further. They go by many names, Kandiyah, Nassasalar, pallbearer, corpse bearer. Regardless of title, their work here is holy. They carry dead bodies to their final resting place, atop stone structures that stand gray against the lush green. These buildings are called Towers of Silence, and this forest exists to protect them. The Towers of Silence are part of a death ritual carried out by Parsi's, a small but
可以踏入。拉什尼不行，我当然更不行。只有这些土地的特殊看守人才能再往里走。他们有很多名字：Kandiyah、Nassasalar、抬棺人、送葬者。无论头衔如何，他们在这里的工作都是神圣的。他们将尸体抬到最后的安息之地，放在那些在郁郁葱葱的绿色中显得灰暗的石质建筑之上。这些建筑被称为“寂静之塔”，而这片森林的存在就是为了保护它们。寂静之塔是帕西人（Parsi）举行死亡仪式的一部分，帕西人是印度一个规模虽小但
prosperous community in India. Parsis practiced Zoroastrianism, a monotheistic religion originally from Iran. Zoroastrians in Iran were persecuted in the seventh century during the rise of the Islamic Empire, and Muslim armies gave surviving Zoroastrians a choice, conversion or exile. Eventually, a small group of Zoroastrians fled Iran for the shores of western India, bringing with them any surviving fragments of tradition.
繁荣的群体。帕西人信奉琐罗亚斯德教（祆教），这是一种起源于伊朗的一神论宗教。伊朗的琐罗亚斯德教徒在公元七世纪伊斯兰帝国兴起期间受到迫害，穆斯林军队给了幸存的琐罗亚斯德教徒一个选择：改宗或流亡。最终，一小群琐罗亚斯德教徒逃离伊朗，来到印度西部海岸，随身携带了任何幸存的传统碎片。
The Parsi's arrived, it is said, men, women and children by way of one boatload. This is Zoroastrian religious scholar Khojeste Mistry. He's been teaching Zoroastrian theology for the last 45 years. There's a popular legend that describes how Zoroastrians arrived in India. When this milk and sugar story began, nobody knows, but it's the most famous story that the Parsis have been told from little children upwards. The story goes like this. When the boat full of Zoroastrians landed in India,
据说，帕西人是乘着一船人抵达的，包括男人、女人和孩子。这是琐罗亚斯德教宗教学者霍杰斯特·米斯特里（Khojeste Mistry）。他在过去45年里一直教授琐罗亚斯德教神学。有一个流行的传说描述了琐罗亚斯德教徒是如何抵达印度的。这个“牛奶和糖”的故事始于何时，没人知道，但这是帕西人从小到大听过的最著名的故事。故事是这样的：当载满琐罗亚斯德教徒的船只在印度登陆时，
the king showed them a bowl that was full to the rim with milk. Khojeste says the intention was to convey that India was already too full, no room for new arrivals. And the Zoroastrian priest, the Dashtur, asked for crystals of sugar. And he was given crystals of sugar and he gently lowered the crystals of sugar into this bowl full of milk. And obviously the milk did not overflow from the bowl. It suggested that not only was there room for his people in India, but that Zoroastrians would enrich Indian society if
国王向他们展示了一个装满牛奶的碗。霍杰斯特说，其意图是传达印度已经太拥挤了，没有新来者的空间。而琐罗亚斯德教的祭司，即“达斯图尔”（Dashtur），要了一些糖晶体。他得到了糖晶体，然后轻轻地将糖晶体放入这碗牛奶中。显然，牛奶并没有从碗里溢出来。这暗示着，不仅印度有容纳他的人民的空间，而且如果
permitted to settle. And the symbolism there was that the Parsis would integrate so well that they would bring sweetness to the land that was giving them sanctuary. From then on, Zoroastrians who settled all over India came to be known as Parsis. Eventually, in the 1600s, Mumbai became their epicenter. This was back when the city was still a collection of swampy, mosquito infested islands, seemingly far enough away from the civilized world.
被允许定居，琐罗亚斯德教徒还会丰富印度社会。其中的象征意义在于，帕西人会融合得非常好，以至于他们会为给予他们庇护的土地带来甜蜜。从那时起，在印度各地定居的琐罗亚斯德教徒被称为帕西人。最终，在17世纪，孟买成为了他们的中心。那时，这座城市还只是一堆沼泽丛生、蚊虫肆虐的岛屿，看起来离文明世界足够遥远。
A few wealthy Parsis bought a vast expanse of land here, and they gave it to the community for one specific purpose. All this land was gifted specifically for purposes of having a Tower of Silence. The Towers of Silence are where Parsi's placed their dead. And despite its imposing Gothic-era name that's used by Parsi's and non-Parsis alike, towers of silence aren't actually all that towering at all.
一些富有的帕西人在这里买下了大片土地，并将其赠予社区，用于一个特定的目的。所有这些土地都是专门为了建造寂静之塔而赠送的。寂静之塔是帕西人安放死者的地方。尽管它有一个被帕西人和非帕西人共同使用的、令人印象深刻的哥特式名称，但寂静之塔实际上并没有那么高耸。
These structures got that name by the British, who wanted an English term to describe them, and in doing so, they made them sound perhaps a bit more grandiose than they actually are. These towers, also known simply as dachmas, are built of stone, usually up to 50 feet tall and up to about 100 feet wide. Imagine something more like an open-aired amphitheater. Each tower is circular and roofless. There are markers indicating where bodies should be placed. And in the very center, there's a deep well, storage for the bones of Parsi bodies. Wherever large clusters of Parsi settled, they would cultivate forests or Tungarvadis and build dachmas inside them. Five dachmas were built here
这些建筑的名字是由英国人取的，他们想要一个英语术语来描述它们，这样做使它们听起来比实际情况稍微宏伟了一些。这些塔，也被简称为“达克玛”（dachmas），是用石头建造的，通常高达50英尺，宽达100英尺左右。想象一下更像是一个露天圆形剧场的东西。每座塔都是圆形的，没有屋顶。有标记指示尸体应该放置在哪里。而在最中心，有一个深井，用于存放帕西人尸体的骨头。无论帕西人聚集在哪里，他们都会开辟森林或“通加瓦迪”（Tungarvadis），并在其中建造达克玛。这里建造了五座达克玛，
in Mumbai, which in total are able to handle over a thousand corpses a year. Zoroastrians have practiced this ritual of sky burial in Mumbai for centuries. According to the faith, as soon as we die, our bodies become contaminated with evil. And this evil must not, under any circumstance, make contact with the sacred elements of fire, water, and earth. Therefore, we cannot bury our dead because that's polluting Mother Earth.
在孟买，总共每年能够处理一千多具尸体。几个世纪以来，琐罗亚斯德教徒一直在孟买实行这种天葬仪式。根据信仰，我们一死，身体就会被邪恶污染。这种邪恶在任何情况下都不得接触火、水和土这三种神圣元素。因此，我们不能埋葬死者，因为那会污染大地母亲。
We cannot burn our dead because that's polluting fire, and fire is seen as the Son of God. So Zoroastrians have always had this unusual method of giving back to nature. By giving back to nature, what Kogeste means is that after priests have said their final prayers, the corpse bearers will place a body atop one of these towers. Then they will wait for the vultures to come. Rashne Bardiwala grew up in a Parsi family,
我们不能火化死者，因为那会污染火，而火被视为上帝之子。所以琐罗亚斯德教徒一直有这种回馈自然的独特方法。科杰斯特所说的“回馈自然”是指，在祭司念完最后的祈祷文后，送葬者会将尸体放在其中一座塔上。然后他们会等待秃鹫的到来。拉什尼·巴迪瓦拉（Rashne Bardiwala）在一个帕西家庭长大，
minutes from the Mumbai Dungarwadi forest, where the towers of silence stand. She remembers the first time she learned about the vultures and their role in consuming Parsi corpses. We were on a family holiday in Gujarat, and we were driving, and I must have been all of possibly five or six years old. Out of their car window,
距离孟买的Dungarwadi森林只有几分钟路程，寂静之塔就矗立在那里。她记得第一次了解秃鹫及其在消耗帕西尸体中的作用。我们在古吉拉特邦度假，当时正在开车，我当时可能只有五六岁。在车窗外，
Rashne's family saw a dead horse on the roadside. They pulled over out of curiosity just to take a closer look. Rashne remembers her father pointing to the sky in awe. He said, oh, look, those are the birds, those are vultures up there circling, and then thought nothing of it, got back into the car and we drove off.
拉什尼的家人看到路边有一匹死马。出于好奇，他们靠边停车，想仔细看看。拉什尼记得她父亲敬畏地指着天空。他说，哦，看，那是鸟，那是秃鹫在上面盘旋，然后就没多想，回到了车里，我们就开车走了。
20 or so minutes later, Rashne and her family drove back down that same road. And that is when all of us were absolutely shocked. I remember dad just slamming on the brakes and stopping because a horse that we had seen dead 15, 20 minutes ago had been completely wiped clean by the vultures. In 15 minutes, that carcass was clean down to the bone. A few vultures were actually still sitting there, perched right next to the skeleton, their bellies too heavy with horse meat to fly.
大约20分钟后，拉什尼和她的家人开车回到了同一条路上。就在那时，我们所有人都感到无比震惊。我记得爸爸猛踩刹车停了下来，因为我们15、20分钟前看到的死马已经被秃鹫啃得干干净净。在15分钟内，那具尸体被清理得只剩下骨头。几只秃鹫实际上还坐在那里，栖息在骨架旁边，肚子因为塞满了马肉而太重，飞不起来。
But to Rushne's family, the scene wasn't grim. And I remember my mother using that opportunity as a learning, saying, oh, you know, this is why they say our mode of disposal of the dead in the Parsi community is the best mode, because it's such a quick, clean, efficient system. This interdependent system between Zoroastrians and the birds who consume the flesh of their dead,
但对拉什尼的家人来说，这一幕并不阴森。我记得我母亲利用那个机会进行教育，说，哦，你知道，这就是为什么他们说我们在帕西社区处理死者的方式是最好的方式，因为它是一个如此快速、干净、高效的系统。这种琐罗亚斯德教徒与消耗他们死者尸体的鸟类之间的相互依存系统，
it's called the Kminishini, and it is ancient. The relationship between vultures and the Parsis, it goes back thousands of years. This is writer Mira Subramanian, who has written at length about vultures in South Asia. She says that, according to some estimates, there were once well over 40 million vultures throughout India. But no one will ever really know. They were so plentiful, in fact, that no scientific efforts were ever made to do a population
被称为“Kminishini”，它是古老的。秃鹫与帕西人之间的关系可以追溯到几千年前。这是作家米拉·苏布拉马尼安（Mira Subramanian），她曾详细撰写过关于南亚秃鹫的文章。她说，据一些估计，印度各地曾经有超过4000万只秃鹫。但没有人会真正知道。事实上，它们数量如此之多，以至于从未进行过任何科学的人口统计。
count. For kids growing up in India, my own parents included, there were far less dogs supposedly eating homework and many more vultures to blame in the classroom instead. As in, sorry I'm late to school, vultures were mid-feed on a roadside carcass blocking traffic again. India's Civil Aviation Department would even hire people
对于在印度长大的孩子，包括我自己的父母，据说吃掉家庭作业的狗要少得多，而在教室里被责怪的秃鹫却多得多。比如，抱歉我上学迟到了，秃鹫又在路边的尸体上进食，挡住了交通。印度的民航部门甚至会雇人
to shoot vultures around airports because they posed such a hazard to air traffic. You know, they were just always there. They were always there and there were so many of them. In this story, we're mostly referring to a genus of vultures called gyps vultures. And these birds, they just have this look about them. The look, you know, not the best. I won't say ugly, but they don't look very attractive as a bird.
在机场周围射杀秃鹫，因为它们对空中交通构成了巨大的危险。你知道，它们总是出现在那里。它们总是出现在那里，而且数量非常多。在这个故事中，我们主要指的是一种被称为“兀鹫”（gyps vultures）的秃鹫。这些鸟，它们看起来就是那样。那种样子，你知道，不是最好的。我不会说丑，但作为一种鸟，它们看起来并不怎么吸引人。
In the sky, vultures loom large, casting an eight-foot shadow with their massive wingspan. And on the ground, sometimes you can only see their bodies, their bald heads often buried deep inside a fresh carcass. Nobody really believes this when I say this, but they're very beautiful. And hey, at least Mira thinks they're pretty. They have this ring of puffy feathers around their neck that reminds me of a Victorian
在天空中，秃鹫显得很大，巨大的翼展投下八英尺长的阴影。而在地面上，有时你只能看到它们的身体，秃头通常深深地埋在新鲜的尸体里。当我这么说时，没人真的相信，但它们非常美丽。嘿，至少米拉认为它们很漂亮。它们的脖子上有一圈蓬松的羽毛，让我想起了一位维多利亚时代的
lady. While vultures are scavengers, often associated with greediness and death, they're actually very shy around people. These are birds that just, they don't like interacting with humans. The most common response if they are disturbed by humans is that they vomit and they fly away. And yet for centuries, a very specific symbiosis played out here in Mumbai, between these vultures, this forest, and the parses. Time passed, wars came and went,
女士。虽然秃鹫是食腐动物，常与贪婪和死亡联系在一起，但它们在人面前其实非常害羞。这些鸟只是不喜欢与人类互动。如果它们被人类打扰，最常见的反应就是呕吐然后飞走。然而几个世纪以来，在孟买，在这些秃鹫、这片森林和帕西人之间，发生了一种非常特殊的共生关系。时光流逝，战争来了又去，
cities grew, trees fell. But this practice survived. In Mumbai, approximately three new bodies were carried up every day. It was an efficient send-off, one in which your body became your final offering to the natural world. Most of all, it was tradition. But this tradition would begin to unravel. I met Aspi a few hours north of Mumbai, in a small town with a large Parsi population. Asbi wore a bright pink and orange blouse that he had hand-sewn, with a large orange heart embroidered onto the front. For more than four decades, Asbi has done the work that goes by many names, the work
城市扩张，树木倒下。但这种习俗幸存了下来。在孟买，每天大约有三具新尸体被抬上去。这是一种高效的送别，你的身体成为了你对自然界的最后奉献。最重要的是，这是一种传统。但这种传统开始瓦解。我在孟买以北几个小时路程的一个拥有大量帕西人口的小镇见到了阿斯皮（Aspi）。阿斯皮穿着一件他亲手缝制的亮粉色和橙色衬衫，前面绣着一颗巨大的橙色心形。四十多年来，阿斯皮一直从事着那个有很多名字的工作，那个
that takes him deep into the Dungarwadi forest where few others can go. I am a NASA Salar in the Parsi religion. In Gujarati, Asbi describes it as the work of giving shoulder, because a large part of his work involves carrying bodies of the deceased on his shoulders. Parsis are actually widely known and stereotyped in India as being a fairly wealthy minority community, but those who work as corpse bearers are often spoken of in hushed tones. Many Kandiyas live right on Dungarvadi grounds, and
带他深入Dungarwadi森林、极少有人能去的工作。我是帕西教的一名“纳萨萨拉”（NASA Salar）。在古吉拉特语中，阿斯皮将其描述为“给予肩膀”的工作，因为他大部分工作涉及用肩膀抬着死者的尸体。帕西人在印度被广泛认知并被刻板印象为相当富有的少数群体，但那些从事送葬工作的人往往被低声谈论。许多Kandiyas就住在Dungarvadi的土地上，而且
because in Zoroastrianism, corpses are believed to have been contaminated with evil, those who handle corpses are often treated as if they're contaminated too. I thought nothing of this when I reached out to shake Asbi's hand, but then I felt his flinch. Will you be able to hear my voice in this mic you brought? Otherwise, I brought my own portable mic."
因为在琐罗亚斯德教中，尸体被认为被邪恶污染了，所以那些处理尸体的人往往也被视为受到了污染。当我伸手去握阿斯皮的手时，我没多想，但随后我感觉到他退缩了。你能在你带来的这个麦克风里听到我的声音吗？否则，我带了我自己的便携式麦克风。
As we sat down, Asbi excitedly pulled out what looked like a large toy microphone out of his pocket. It was golden and battery-powered, and it immediately started playing the radio. Asbi said he'd brought it in case mine wasn't up to par. Bluetooth mount. Hello. I told Asby that I wanted to talk to him about the vultures. His blue eyes went wide. I hope you're not in a hurry, he said.
当我们坐下时，阿斯皮兴奋地从口袋里掏出一个看起来像大玩具麦克风的东西。它是金色的，电池供电，而且立刻开始播放广播。阿斯皮说他带它是为了以防我的麦克风不够好。蓝牙挂载。你好。我告诉阿斯皮我想和他谈谈秃鹫的事。他的蓝眼睛睁大了。我希望你不赶时间，他说。
I hope you're not in a hurry," he said. I had time, but I didn't exactly have space. The room Aspi and I were in was full of Parsi elders, and there was nothing I could say to convince them to leave, especially since it's unusual for Kandiyas to speak publicly like this. I grew up around several nosy Indian aunties, though, not to mention I live in fear of becoming one. So I get it. With a little coaxing, I got each uncle to please mute their WhatsApp notifications.
“我希望你不赶时间，”他说。我有时间，但我并没有确切的空间。我和阿斯皮所在的房间里挤满了帕西长辈，我无法说服他们离开，尤其是因为Kandiyas像这样公开讲话是不寻常的。不过，我是在几个爱管闲事的印度阿姨身边长大的，更不用说我一直害怕自己也会变成那样。所以我明白。在一点点劝说下，我让每位叔叔都把他们的WhatsApp通知静音。
Then usbees started to speak. And I swear I could feel everyone around us lean in. When I was 12 or 13, my grandmother died, and one of the four corpse bearers in our town had fallen sick. So I was asked, son, will you come help? I had never been before. My father initially refused. He said, Aspi is only a child. He will get scared. But there was a need, so Aspi stepped in to help give his grandmother a proper send-off. Typically after a Parsi dies, there are four days of
然后阿斯皮开始说话。我发誓我能感觉到周围每个人都凑了过来。我12或13岁时，我祖母去世了，我们镇上的四名送葬者中有一名病倒了。所以我被问到，孩子，你愿意来帮忙吗？我以前从未去过。我父亲起初拒绝了。他说，阿斯皮还是个孩子。他会害怕的。但有需求，所以阿斯皮介入帮忙，给了他祖母一个体面的送别。通常在帕西人去世后，会有四天的
prayers held at the closest Tungarwadi, the forest where the towers are built. First, the body is ritually bathed and then carried to one of the towers. One person opens the door and then we take the body inside. Once inside, they lay the body to rest on a stone slab. When I went inside, all these birds were looking like trustees in a board meeting. They were just watching us staring. Based on that description, it seems apt that the collective noun for a group of vultures is called a committee.
祈祷在最近的通加瓦迪（Tungarwadi）举行，也就是建造塔的森林。首先，尸体被仪式性地沐浴，然后被抬到其中一座塔上。一个人打开门，然后我们把尸体抬进去。进去后，他们把尸体放在石板上安息。当我进去时，所有的鸟看起来都像董事会会议上的受托人。它们只是盯着我们看。根据那个描述，秃鹫群的集体名词被称为“委员会”（committee）似乎很贴切。
And they were making sounds like this. Sometimes Aspi and his fellow corpse bearers would have to stave off the vultures with iron rods until all the rituals were complete. And once the body is placed inside, they pounce and eat. That's it. The vultures would set to their task, often taking just 30 minutes to get from body to bone. Then the corpse bearers would sweep the bones into the central well. Three or four days later, someone else expired.
它们发出的声音是这样的。有时阿斯皮和他的送葬同伴不得不拿着铁棒抵御秃鹫，直到所有仪式完成。一旦尸体被放入，它们就会扑上去吃。就是这样。秃鹫会开始它们的工作，通常只需30分钟就能从尸体吃到骨头。然后送葬者会把骨头扫进中央深井。三四天后，又有人去世了。
And again my uncle asked me, Aspi Gadiali, will you come with us? I said yes. The next time I entered the towers to carry the second body, we laid it right next to my grandmother's and I saw that my grandmother's body was totally finished as in everything was eaten not one thing was left of her only bones. When I tried to sleep that night, my mind kept playing those images like a tape recorder on repeat. It was like a horror movie in my mind, on replay.
我叔叔又问我，阿斯皮·加迪亚利（Aspi Gadiali），你愿意和我们一起去吗？我说愿意。下一次我进入塔内抬第二具尸体时，我们把它放在了我祖母的旁边，我看到我祖母的身体已经完全消失了，也就是说一切都被吃掉了，她身上什么都没剩下，只剩下骨头。那天晚上我试图睡觉时，我的大脑一直在像录音机一样反复播放那些画面。就像我脑海里的一部恐怖电影，在重播。
But then Asbi got quiet, and he looked at me apologetically. I can't tell you anything more about what happens inside. If I share in any more detail, I will have to pay for it in my next life. After all, this is a sacred ritual, and when it comes to death, there are some things that are just not spoken. Eventually, Aspi began working full time as a kandhya, and he took great pride in this role. Day after day, Parsi corpse bearers like Aspi
但随后阿斯皮安静了下来，他歉意地看着我。关于里面发生的事情，我不能再告诉你更多了。如果我分享更多细节，我下辈子得付出代价。毕竟，这是一个神圣的仪式，当涉及到死亡时，有些事情是不能说的。最终，阿斯皮开始全职担任Kandhya，他为这个角色感到非常自豪。日复一日，像阿斯皮这样的帕西送葬者
would carry a body atop a dakma while vultures would watch from their perch. Then they'd step back, and the vultures would swoop in. This was how it worked for centuries, a seamless cycle of life and death passed on from one generation to the next, until one thing changed, or rather disappeared, and then everything started to topple. It was a very ecological and beautiful process in so many ways, and that just
会把尸体抬到达克玛（dakma）上，而秃鹫会在它们的栖木上观看。然后他们退后，秃鹫就会俯冲下来。几个世纪以来一直如此，这是一个从一代传给下一代的无缝生命与死亡循环，直到一件事发生了变化，或者说消失了，然后一切都开始崩塌。这在许多方面是一个非常生态且美丽的进程，而那
came crashing to a halt. In the early 80s, Aspi noticed that there were fewer and fewer vultures sitting and waiting at their usual perch. Back then, we thought that it is a bird. Maybe it had moved somewhere else. Maybe their lifespan was short and they were towards the end of it. We could not understand why their population had decreased. Kandiyas all over India seem to be noticing this mysterious trend atop their respective
戛然而止。80年代初，阿斯皮注意到坐在它们通常栖木上等待的秃鹫越来越少了。那时，我们想，它是一只鸟。也许它搬到别处去了。也许它们的寿命很短，它们已经接近生命尽头了。我们无法理解为什么它们的数量会减少。印度各地的Kandiyas似乎都在各自的
towers inside their respective dungarvadis. They would carry a few new bodies into the towers, only to find that yesterday's bodies were still untouched by vultures. Then, it seemed like all the vultures had disappeared altogether. Their absence was felt outside the Parsi community too. Vultures have scoured the countryside and cleaned up
塔顶、各自的通加瓦迪（dungarvadis）内注意到了这种神秘的趋势。他们会把几具新尸体抬进塔里，结果发现昨天的尸体仍然没有被秃鹫触碰。然后，似乎所有的秃鹫都完全消失了。它们的缺席在帕西社区之外也被感受到了。秃鹫在整个乡村搜寻并清理了
dead cattle and roadkill for all of human history. So eventually, more people across the country began to notice that they were gone. In the late 1990s, a group of villagers in Rajasthan observed that when cows would die in the fields, their carcasses would sit and rot for days, which was extremely unusual. Luckily, they knew exactly who to contact. They said the vultures are declining and they were very worried
死牛和路杀动物，贯穿了整个人类历史。所以最终，全国各地更多的人开始注意到它们不见了。90年代末，拉贾斯坦邦的一群村民观察到，当牛在田野里死亡时，它们的尸体会躺在那里腐烂好几天，这非常不寻常。幸运的是，他们确切地知道该联系谁。他们说秃鹫正在减少，他们非常担心，
because their dead cattle were not being disposed of. This is Dr. Vibhu Prakash, India's leading vulture biologist and conservationist. People were telling Vibhu that the vultures had disappeared, like poof. Many thought they were stolen or poisoned. The villagers were like, maybe it was the Americans, which, you know. So when villagers told me that this is what is happening, I really started looking for dead vultures.
因为他们的死牛没有被处理掉。这是维布·普拉卡什（Vibhu Prakash）博士，印度领先的秃鹫生物学家和保护主义者。人们告诉维布，秃鹫消失了，就像“砰”的一声。许多人认为它们被偷了或中毒了。村民们说，也许是美国人干的，你知道的。所以当村民们告诉我发生了什么事时，我真的开始寻找死秃鹫。
And then I found dead vultures all over, in the bushes, on the trees, everywhere. The reality was that vultures were often dying, not on the ground, but up in trees and bushes, where it was hard to spot them. So it did kind of look like they'd vanished. But you didn't have to see the dead vultures to know that something was very wrong.
然后我在灌木丛中、树上、到处都发现了死秃鹫。现实情况是，秃鹫经常死亡，不是在地上，而是在树上和灌木丛中，很难发现它们。所以看起来它们确实消失了。但你不必看到死秃鹫就知道出了大问题。
Strengths itself was a problem. Then you see the increase in flies, maggots. And you know, by 2000, we realized that this problem is much bigger than we can handle on our own. Desperate to stave off extinction, Vibhu sounded the alarm. And because vulture populations were declining across all of South Asia, he turned to the international scientific community for help. Together, they ran through theories from food shortage to habitat loss. They looked into the possibility of contagious disease,
腐烂本身就是一个问题。然后你看到苍蝇、蛆虫在增加。你知道，到2000年，我们意识到这个问题比我们自己能处理的要大得多。为了阻止灭绝，维布敲响了警钟。由于整个南亚的秃鹫数量都在下降，他向国际科学界寻求帮助。他们一起研究了从食物短缺到栖息地丧失的各种理论。他们调查了传染病的可能性，
but nothing was conclusive. Then, finally, in 2003, they made a shocking discovery. The vultures had been dying of kidney failure, and the culprit was a prescription painkiller, similar to ibuprofen, called Diclofenac. What is Diclofenac? Diclofenac is a cheap drug that was first introduced in the 1970s for the treatment of arthritis and pain management in humans.
但没有结论。然后，终于在2003年，他们有了惊人的发现。秃鹫死于肾衰竭，罪魁祸首是一种类似于布洛芬的处方止痛药，叫做双氯芬酸（Diclofenac）。什么是双氯芬酸？双氯芬酸是一种廉价药物，最初于20世纪70年代引入，用于治疗人类的关节炎和疼痛管理。
By the early 1990s, diclofenac became a veterinary painkiller, and because of its recently expired patent it ended up being the cheapest and most popular livestock drug on the market. Hinduism's reverence for cows means that in India, most cattle are left to die naturally in the fields, where vultures would reliably finish the job. Farmers would give diclofenac to cows, and then when those cows died with diclofenac in their system, vultures would eat them and get poisoned by the drug.
到90年代初，双氯芬酸成为了一种兽用止痛药，由于其专利刚过期，它最终成为市场上最便宜、最受欢迎的牲畜药物。印度教对牛的崇敬意味着在印度，大多数牛被留在田野里自然死亡，秃鹫会可靠地完成清理工作。农民会给牛喂双氯芬酸，然后当这些体内含有双氯芬酸的牛死亡时，秃鹫会吃掉它们并被药物毒死。
Because India has the largest cattle population in the world, this was happening at an enormous scale. And this is when the vulture deaths became a national crisis. The irony of an over-the-counter ibuprofen knockoff decimating the vulture population is that this bird is uniquely known for its biological resilience. The vulture has a superb digestion system and it can actually even survive doses of arsenic. Their incredibly strong stomach acids have allowed them to consume diseases like tuberculosis,
因为印度拥有世界上最多的牛群，这种情况正在大规模发生。就在这时，秃鹫死亡事件演变成了一场国家危机。一种非处方布洛芬仿制品摧毁了秃鹫种群，其讽刺之处在于，这种鸟以其独特的生物韧性而闻名。秃鹫拥有极好的消化系统，甚至可以承受砷的剂量。它们极其强大的胃酸使它们能够消耗结核病、
rabies, even anthrax, and face no consequence. But this diclofenic was the knockout thing. Ultimately, what killed them was a drug humans created to relieve us of our pains. In less than a decade since Vibhu was first contacted by those villagers, India had lost up to 99% of its gyps vultures. It was probably the steepest decline ever recorded anywhere in the world of any species which I know of. It was astonishing.
狂犬病，甚至是炭疽病，而不会产生任何后果。但这种双氯芬酸是致命的打击。最终，杀死它们的是人类为了缓解自身痛苦而创造的药物。在维布首次被那些村民联系后的不到十年里，印度失去了高达99%的兀鹫。这可能是世界上任何物种有记录以来最陡峭的下降。这令人震惊。
Three years after the mystery had been solved, India banned the veterinary use of diclofenac. But banning the drug outright is really hard to put into practice. The fact of the matter is that the black market is really thriving in India. So you had illegal production of Diclofenac that continues to this day. In addition to Diclofenac, there are now four more livestock drugs in circulation in India
谜题解开三年后，印度禁止了双氯芬酸的兽用。但彻底禁止这种药物在实践中非常困难。事实是，黑市在印度确实很猖獗。所以非法生产的双氯芬酸一直持续到今天。除了双氯芬酸，现在印度还有四种牲畜药物在流通，
today that have been found to be just as deadly to vultures. And even though the Indian government finally banned two of these drugs in 2023, it doesn't undo the damage done years ago. Today, the number of gyps, vultures, and Indian skies are nowhere near what they once were. ["The Day of the Vulture"] Even before the vulture die-off began,
今天被发现对秃鹫同样致命。即使印度政府终于在2023年禁止了其中两种药物，也无法挽回多年前造成的损害。今天，印度天空中的兀鹫数量远不及从前。["秃鹫之日"] 甚至在秃鹫死亡开始之前，
every now and again, Parsi's would question the ancient ritual of Dhakmeneshini in the way that people always do with old traditions. But now, with this mass vulture death, Parsi's were grappling with the fate of their corpses in a new and urgent way. Welcome back to the debate between dignity versus tradition sparked by the tower of silence controversy. Well, the controversy really began to rage when the task stopped working. In other words, when the vultures disappeared.
帕西人偶尔也会像人们对待古老传统那样质疑“Dhakmeneshini”的古老仪式。但现在，随着这次大规模秃鹫死亡，帕西人正以一种新的、紧迫的方式应对他们尸体的命运。欢迎回到由寂静之塔争议引发的尊严与传统之间的辩论。嗯，当任务停止工作时，争议真的开始激烈起来。换句话说，当秃鹫消失时。
No one for many years had an answer to that mystery until the mystery began to unravel and it was linked to the wider disappearance of vultures, not just in Bombay, but across India. In Mumbai, about three Parsis were dying a day. So Kandiyas like Aspi continued to lay bodies atop their towers, this time for vultures that would no longer come. Now they do not come at all.
多年来，没有人能回答那个谜题，直到谜题开始解开，它与秃鹫更广泛的消失联系在一起，不仅是在孟买，而是在整个印度。在孟买，每天大约有三名帕西人死亡。所以像阿斯皮这样的Kandiyas继续把尸体放在他们的塔上，这一次是为那些不再来的秃鹫准备的。现在它们根本不来了。
It has completely stopped. They all stopped coming and now there is not even one. How will they come back? Where do I go and call them from? Much smaller birds of prey now descend on the towers, but when it comes to consuming corpses they're inefficient and messy. There are black kites in Mumbai. You go to the grounds today and there's tons of birds flying around. But black kites, let's just say they have different eating habits. They like the little tender tasty bits and then they leave the rest.
它已经完全停止了。它们都停止了到来，现在连一只都没有了。它们怎么会回来？我去哪里把它们叫回来？现在有更小的猛禽降落在塔上，但当涉及到消耗尸体时，它们效率低下且肮脏。孟买有黑鸢。你今天去那里，到处都是飞来飞去的鸟。但黑鸢，我们只能说它们有不同的饮食习惯。它们喜欢那些嫩嫩的美味部分，然后留下其余的。
So it doesn't do what the vultures did in terms of cleaning up a body completely. And so maybe just the fact that there were like big black birds flying around, that was enough to make people think, oh everything was fine. But everything wasn't fine. All you had to do was ask their neighbors. These smaller birds of prey would sometimes leave them disturbing little treats. This is a really nice tone-y part of town and there are luxury high-rises, and I heard more than one Parsi joke about fingers showing up while you're having your avocado toast
所以它不像秃鹫那样能把尸体清理得干干净净。所以也许仅仅是因为有像大黑鸟一样的东西飞来飞去，这就足以让人们认为，哦，一切都很好。但一切并不好。你所要做的就是问问他们的邻居。这些较小的猛禽有时会留下令人不安的小礼物。这是一个非常好的城镇区域，有豪华高层建筑，我听到不止一个帕西人开玩笑说，当你在阳台上吃牛油果吐司时，手指会冒出来。
in the morning on your balcony. The neighborhood adjacent to the Mumbai Dungarwadi today, Malabar Hill, is one of the wealthiest and most exclusive in the city, and it's home to many rich Parsi's. Realtors actually advertise the proximity to the lush Thangarvadi forest as a major value add. And I mean, it is so rare in Mumbai to get to be so close to green space, to get to look out your window and see a forest. But these neighbors would complain about getting a view and a smell that they didn't quite
今天与孟买Dungarwadi相邻的社区，马拉巴尔山（Malabar Hill），是城里最富有、最独特的社区之一，也是许多富裕帕西人的家园。房地产经纪人实际上将靠近郁郁葱葱的Thangarvadi森林作为主要的增值点。我的意思是，在孟买能如此靠近绿地，能从窗户望出去看到一片森林，真是太罕见了。但这些邻居会抱怨得到了一种他们并没有完全
sign up for. One day in the late 1990s, a handful of residents from a nearby apartment building wrote an angry letter. This letter made its way to the Bombay Parsi Panchayat, which is the leadership committee that oversees Parsi community affairs in Mumbai. My name is Dinsha Tamboli. I'm 79 years of age, but feeling more like 39. Dinsha was a member of the panchayat at the time, and he was in charge of all things dhokminashini. You have to speak loud. I'm a little bit harder of hearing.
预期的视野和气味。90年代末的一天，附近一栋公寓楼的几位居民写了一封愤怒的信。这封信传到了孟买帕西潘查亚特（Bombay Parsi Panchayat），这是负责监督孟买帕西社区事务的领导委员会。我叫丁沙·坦博利（Dinsha Tamboli）。我79岁了，但感觉更像39岁。丁沙当时是潘查亚特的成员，他负责所有关于“dhokminashini”的事情。你必须大声说话。我听力有点困难。
Okay. I've got this hearing aid job. Okay. First things first, tea, coffee. — Over a cup of chai, Dinshaw told me about this angry letter. — They wrote to us that awful stench is emanating from there and they are not able to keep their windows open. They have to keep their windows shut, keep the air conditioners on 24 hours, and something
好的。我有这个助听器工作。好的。首先，茶，咖啡。——喝着一杯印度奶茶，丁沙告诉了我这封愤怒的信。——他们写信给我们说，那里散发出恶臭，他们无法开窗。他们必须关上窗户，24小时开着空调，应该做点什么。
should be done. This letter is from over 20 years ago, but Dinshaw still has a crisp paper copy in his office drawer, and he handed it to me, silently. It says, dear trustees, these pictures are taken from the top floor of New Skyscraper that is under construction, and are taken with special telescopic photo sensor lenses
这封信是20多年前写的，但丁沙的办公室抽屉里仍然有一份清晰的纸质副本，他默默地递给了我。上面写着，亲爱的受托人，这些照片是从正在建设中的新摩天大楼顶层拍摄的，是用特殊的伸缩式光电传感器镜头拍摄的，
that are used for photographing far off objects. Can bodies be allowed to lie like this? We demand that the system that is followed must be changed immediately. We are sending copies of these pictures to Delhi, Prime Minister, Home Minister, Environmental Ministry in Mumbai, Chief Minister, Health Minister, Mayor, Municipal Commissioner, Health Officer. It is shocking that Parsis are forced to
这些镜头用于拍摄远处的物体。尸体可以这样放吗？我们要求必须立即改变所遵循的系统。我们正在将这些照片的副本发送给德里、总理、内政部长、孟买环境部、首席部长、卫生部长、市长、市政专员、卫生官员。令人震惊的是，帕西人被迫
follow this outdated system. Well, yeah. Because of the absence of vultures, the bodies atop the towers were barely being consumed. To be clear, these bodies were piling up and mostly just rotting. And from a distance, the apartment residents could see and smell them. It was Dinshaw's responsibility to figure out what to do. First, he decided to do some fact checking. Dinshaw wanted to see for himself whether the complaints about the sight and the smell held up. So even though it was against the rules, he asked Akandya to let him into one of the towers. And was anybody surprised that you were asking to do that?
遵循这种过时的系统。嗯，是的。由于秃鹫的缺失，塔上的尸体几乎没有被消耗。说清楚点，这些尸体堆积起来，大部分只是在腐烂。从远处看，公寓居民可以看到并闻到它们。弄清楚该怎么办是丁沙的责任。首先，他决定做一些事实核查。丁沙想亲自看看关于视觉和气味的投诉是否属实。所以尽管违反了规定，他还是要求一位Akandya让他进入其中一座塔。有人对你要求这样做感到惊讶吗？
Because- Yes, he asked that, he told me that, sir, what you're asking, I'll do. He couldn't say no to me. But there'll be absolute mayhem in the community. Absolutely, a lot of people will protest, you are not supposed to look inside. I said, it's fine.
因为——是的，他问了，他告诉我，先生，你要求的，我会做。他不能拒绝我。但社区里会发生绝对的混乱。当然，很多人会抗议，你不应该往里看。我说，没关系。
I'm only doing my duty. What I saw was horrific. And that's all that Dinshah would tell me. Because again, this is a sacred ritual. And when it comes to death, there are some things that are just not spoken. Dinshah turned to the kandiyya and asked him, basically, how did this happen?
我只是在履行我的职责。我所看到的是可怕的。这就是丁沙愿意告诉我的全部。因为同样，这是一个神圣的仪式。当涉及到死亡时，有些事情是不能说的。丁沙转向Kandiyya，基本上问他，这是怎么发生的？
And did you ever ask them, how come you didn't share this? I did ask them. They said that, look, we at once told the trustees that this is a scenario and they said, rubbish, you're talking rubbish. This cannot be true. And if you persist in making this, you'll all lose your jobs.
你有没有问过他们，为什么你们不分享这个？我确实问过他们。他们说，看，我们曾经告诉过受托人这是一个场景，他们说，胡说八道，你在胡说八道。这不可能是真的。如果你坚持要制造这个，你们都会丢掉工作。
He said, what should we do? We have to look after our own life. So we started telling them what they wanted to hear from us. A few days later, Dinshah told his colleagues in the panchayat, look, we have a serious issue. And I know because I saw it with my own eyes. What was their reaction?
他说，我们该怎么办？我们必须照顾好自己的生活。所以我们开始告诉他们他们想从我们这里听到的东西。几天后，丁沙告诉他在潘查亚特的同事，看，我们有一个严重的问题。我知道，因为我亲眼看到了。他们的反应是什么？
You shouldn't have done that. I said I just wanted to get to the, understand the reality of it, because of the complaints that we are receiving. Everybody knew that the system was gradually deteriorating, going down because of the lack of vultures. What was not known was the extent to which it had collapsed, the system had collapsed. According to Dinshah, Dakh Manashini has fallen apart. He'd say this matter-of-factly more than a few times.
你不应该那样做。我说我只是想了解现实情况，因为我们收到的投诉。每个人都知道这个系统正在逐渐恶化，因为缺乏秃鹫而走下坡路。不为人知的是它崩溃的程度，系统已经崩溃了。据丁沙说，“Dakh Manashini”已经分崩离析了。他不止一次实事求是地这样说。
Often he'd quickly follow that up with an even gloomier statement. The future of the Parsis as a people is also in trouble. Our numbers have been declining since 1941. As per the 1941 census, there were 114,000 Parsis in India. Since that time, every 10 years, there has been a decline. The government figures are there. With a near permanent shrug in his shoulders, Dinshaw explained the strict rules around
通常他会很快跟上一句更阴郁的话。帕西人作为一个民族的未来也陷入了困境。自1941年以来，我们的人数一直在下降。根据1941年的人口普查，印度有114,000名帕西人。从那时起，每10年就有一次下降。政府数据就在那里。丁沙耸了耸肩，解释了围绕
conversion and intermarriage, the trend of fewer Parsi's having children. Their population has been shrinking too, alongside the vultures. You know how sometimes there'll be a word in the English language that seems simple but has just a stupid amount of different meanings? I've been thinking a lot about this one particular word, wake, as in W-A-K-E, wake. And yes, I was a spelling bee kid who was made to spell this word. And yes, I will give you a definition. To wake from something can mean to make a realization
改宗和通婚的严格规定，以及越来越少帕西人生育孩子的趋势。他们的人口也一直在萎缩，与秃鹫一起。你知道有时英语中会有一个词看起来很简单，但却有愚蠢数量的不同含义吗？我一直在思考这个特定的词，“wake”，即W-A-K-E，wake。是的，我曾经是一个拼写比赛的孩子，被迫拼写这个词。是的，我会给你一个定义。从某事中醒来（wake）可能意味着在一段时间的睡眠或不知情后
or discovery after a period of being asleep or unaware. A wake is also a vigil for someone who has just died, a form of honoring or celebrating the life of the deceased. And awake, it also happens to be the collective noun for a group of vultures who are mid-feed on a plan. By this point, by the way, it's 2001, and there are two clusters of tall apartment buildings peering over Dungarwadi.
实现或发现。守灵（wake）也是为刚刚去世的人举行的守夜活动，一种纪念或庆祝死者生命的形式。而“awake”，恰好也是秃鹫群在进食时的集体名词。顺便说一句，到这一点时，已经是2001年了，有两群高层公寓楼俯瞰着Dungarwadi。
Some towers were going unused at the time, and they wanted to figure out if people were getting a view of those towers too. So Dinshah laid down on each stone slab of the empty towers, and he asked residents on the top floors of the surrounding apartment buildings if they could see him. So basically, you were on the phone while laying down on one of these slabs,
当时有些塔没有被使用，他们想弄清楚人们是否也能看到那些塔。所以丁沙躺在空塔的每一块石板上，他问周围公寓楼顶层的居民是否能看到他。所以基本上，你一边躺在这些石板上，一边在打电话，
and somebody else was as well. And your friend would tell you, oh, no, I can see you. Wow, so it really factored into your decision-making in a big way. One of the few living persons who has slept in the slab. Wow, that's pretty funny. Ultimately, Dinshaw found that two of the five towers at Dungarwadi could be seen from apartment windows. As a result, they stopped using those two towers. Atop the remaining towers, the Panchayat, the Parsi leadership council, agreed to begin
而别人也在这样做。你的朋友会告诉你，哦，不，我能看到你。哇，所以它确实在很大程度上影响了你的决策。少数睡在石板上的活人之一。哇，那真是有趣。最终，丁沙发现Dungarwadi的五座塔中有两座可以从公寓窗户看到。结果，他们停止使用那两座塔。在剩下的塔顶上，潘查亚特，即帕西领导委员会，同意开始
conducting a series of experiments. Their goal was to find a way to speed up decomposition, or at the very least, to hide the view and smell of the rotting bodies. First they tried lining the outer rim of the towers with a particular flower called kevra that smells thick and perfumey. If you have urdhan pots outside the walls and put in that flour and add water, and it will give out a very pungent smell, which will mask the smell.
进行一系列实验。他们的目标是找到一种加速分解的方法，或者至少隐藏腐烂尸体的视觉和气味。首先，他们尝试在塔的外缘衬上一种叫做“kevra”的特殊花朵，这种花闻起来很浓郁，有香水味。如果你在墙外放上花盆，放入那种花并加水，它会散发出一种非常刺鼻的气味，这会掩盖气味。
But it wasn't doing quite enough. Then there was brief excitement about a special mixture of herbs and chemicals, the idea being that when stuffed into orifices of the dead, maybe this mixture could speed up decomposition before the smell of rotting flesh kicks in. It accelerated the process of decomposition, but it had a counter effect. The whole area inside became very sludgy. The chemicals were almost too effective.
但这还不够。然后，人们对一种特殊的草药和化学混合物感到短暂的兴奋，想法是当塞进死者的孔窍时，也许这种混合物可以在腐烂肉体的气味出现之前加速分解。它加速了分解过程，但产生了反效果。里面的整个区域变得非常泥泞。这些化学物质的效果几乎太好了。
The floor atop the towers became a kind of human slurry. And a couple of pallbearers slipped, fell into the central well. They had to be brought out. The pallbearers had trouble moving the bodies. And the worst thing was the pallbearas refused to use this composition because they said that when they lift the bodies to put them in the central bell, it was a very messy thing. The arms would come out, the legs would come out that way. From behind closed doors at weekly Panchayat board meetings and on the forums of community newspapers, Parsis discussed any possible solutions they could think of. Parsis living in diaspora all over the world started to write in with suggestions.
塔顶的地面变成了一种人类泥浆。几名抬棺人滑倒，掉进了中央深井。他们不得不被救出来。抬棺人在搬运遗体时遇到了困难。最糟糕的是，抬棺人拒绝使用这种组合，因为他们说，当他们抬起遗体放入中央深井时，场面非常混乱。手臂会掉出来，腿也会以那种方式掉出来。在每周的潘查亚特（Panchayat）董事会闭门会议上，以及社区报纸的论坛上，帕西人讨论了他们能想到的任何可能的解决方案。世界各地的帕西侨民也开始写信提出建议。
There was so much internal dialogue going on within the Parsi community, the Orthodox ones who said, no, this is the only way we can dispose of the dead. Those who were pro-adaptation, who already acknowledged that Parsis were all over the world and were not doing sky burials in so many of the diaspora that was all over the place if they weren't in Mumbai, where the towers were. So all these questions came up about adaptation and survival. Some suggested they use gasification, which involves high heat, or permeation, a technique in Sweden that uses liquid nitrogen to deep freeze a body before vibrating it into a fine powder.
帕西社区内部进行了大量的对话，正统派人士说，不，这是我们处理死者的唯一方式。那些支持适应性改革的人则承认，帕西人遍布世界各地，在孟买以外的许多侨居地并没有进行天葬。因此，关于适应和生存的所有这些问题都出现了。一些人建议使用气化法，这涉及高温；或者使用瑞典的一种渗透技术，即在将遗体振动成细粉之前，先用液氮将其深度冷冻。
One entomologist in Germany suggested they try flesh-eating insects. But no one could agree on any one solution. Nothing compared to the efficiency, cleanliness, and theological alignment of the vultures. Eventually, though, the Bombay-Parsi panchayat landed on a plan. They would install solar panels on the towers. Solar panels, or solar concentrators as they're often called, would essentially look like giant mirrors. Aspi Gadiali remembers working as a corpse bearer during this transition.
德国的一位昆虫学家建议他们尝试食肉昆虫。但没有人能就任何一种解决方案达成一致。没有什么能比得上秃鹫的效率、清洁度和神学一致性。不过，孟买帕西潘查亚特最终还是达成了一个计划。他们将在塔上安装太阳能电池板。太阳能电池板，或者通常所说的太阳能聚光器，本质上看起来就像巨大的镜子。阿斯皮·加迪亚利（Aspi Gadiali）记得在这一过渡时期担任过抬棺人。
The rays of the sun fall on the mirror and then they reflect back to the body. So when the heat of the sun falls on the body, the body melts. You know, like how you put the butter in a frying pan to make pav bhaji, the butter melts, and this is how the body diffuses. The Panchayat hoped that the solar panels would speed up decomposition without involving contact with fire, water, or earth, per Zoroastrian tradition. Solar panels were installed first in Mumbai's Dungarwadi and then atop towers of silence all over India. It might sound gruesome, but bodies melting or dehydrating is far better than just rotting.
太阳光线落在镜子上，然后反射回遗体上。所以当太阳的热量落在遗体上时，遗体就会融化。你知道，就像你把黄油放在平底锅里做帕夫巴吉（pav bhaji）一样，黄油融化了，遗体就是这样消散的。潘查亚特希望太阳能电池板能加速分解，而无需按照琐罗亚斯德教的传统接触火、水或土。太阳能电池板首先安装在孟买的邓加瓦迪（Dungarwadi），随后安装在印度各地的寂静之塔顶部。这听起来可能很可怕，但遗体融化或脱水远比腐烂要好。
And although some had misgivings about the change, calling it backdoor cremation, it mostly seemed like a massive relief that some sort of a solution had finally been found instead of leaving a body to rot for months. The solar concentrators felt like a collective exhale, a triumph of human engineering, a cause for celebration. But all that changed when one woman's grief and rage propelled the Parsi community into a new level of reckoning. And then five years later, Dhan Barya comes into the picture. And turns the world around, tops it away.
尽管有些人对这种改变有顾虑，称其为“后门火葬”，但这似乎在很大程度上是一种巨大的解脱，因为终于找到了一种解决方案，而不是让遗体腐烂数月。太阳能聚光器让人感到如释重负，这是人类工程学的胜利，值得庆祝。但当一位女性的悲伤和愤怒将帕西社区推向了一个新的清算水平时，一切都改变了。五年后，丹·巴里亚（Dhan Barya）出现在了画面中。她扭转了局面，彻底改变了一切。
We'll be back after this. We're back with producer Lashama Don. In 2005, four years after construction began on the solar panels, a Parsi woman named Dhan Bharia laid her 85-year-old mother, Nargis Bharia, to rest at the Mumbai Dungarwadi. Dhan had cut short her career as a touring folk singer to look after her bedridden mother, whom she had lived with for 56 years. After her mom died, Dhan felt lonely and utterly bereft,
广告后回来。我们回到了制片人拉沙玛·多恩（Lashama Don）身边。2005年，在太阳能电池板开始施工四年后，一位名叫丹·巴里亚（Dhan Bharia）的帕西女性将她85岁的母亲纳吉斯·巴里亚（Nargis Bharia）安葬在孟买的邓加瓦迪。丹缩短了她作为巡回民谣歌手的职业生涯，以照顾卧床不起的母亲，她与母亲共同生活了56年。母亲去世后，丹感到孤独和彻底的丧失感，
and she took to spending long hours at Dungarwadi, praying. Dhan was a very pious, devout type of... She used to pray every day from the book, etc. And she used to go quite often to the Dungarvai to pray before the tower in which her mother was consigned. On her visits, Dhan would make small talk with the staff. One afternoon, almost a year after her mother's death, Dhan had an unusual interaction with one of the kandiyas on duty.
她开始花很长时间在邓加瓦迪祈祷。丹是一个非常虔诚、笃信的人……她过去每天都从书里祈祷等等。她经常去邓加瓦迪，在她母亲被安放的塔前祈祷。在访问期间，丹会和工作人员闲聊。一天下午，在母亲去世近一年后，丹与一名当值的抬棺人（kandiyas）进行了一次不同寻常的互动。
She was going back to the towers to pay her respects and do her prayers and you know she just asked the kandiyas like, oh so my mother's gone right? And they're like, no, she's still up there, there's no vultures, where would she go? And this niggled at her and this laughed and said, your mom is still inside. If you want, I can show you. So that was the trigger for her. Like everyone else, Dunn knew that the vultures were gone, but she believed, like most in her community, that the solar panel technology had fully decomposed her mother's body. And she was understandably horrified thinking about her mother naked up on top of this tower
她回到塔前表达敬意并进行祈祷，你知道，她只是问抬棺人：“哦，所以我母亲已经走了，对吧？”他们回答说：“不，她还在上面，没有秃鹫，她能去哪儿呢？”这让她感到不安，那人笑着说：“你妈妈还在里面。如果你想，我可以带你看。”这就是触发她的导火索。像其他人一样，丹知道秃鹫已经消失了，但她像社区里的大多数人一样，相信太阳能电池板技术已经完全分解了她母亲的遗体。想到母亲赤身裸体地躺在塔顶，她感到非常恐惧，
slowly rotting. Dunn wasn't just thinking about her mother. She was thinking about all the mothers. She wasn't a person to just sit on her heels and complain about something or stew about it or write a nice letter of complaint. That just wasn't her style. Dunn wanted the Parsi community to know that these solar panels weren't working as well as people thought they were, especially during India's four-month-long monsoon season,
慢慢腐烂。丹想到的不仅仅是她的母亲。她想到的是所有的母亲。她不是那种只会坐着抱怨或为此焦虑，或者写一封漂亮的投诉信的人。那不是她的风格。丹希望帕西社区知道，这些太阳能电池板并没有人们想象的那么有效，尤其是在印度长达四个月的季风季节期间，
when there isn't enough sunlight for the solar panels to really work. Dunn wanted to tell people that their deceased loved ones were decomposing slowly, that their souls weren't free. Photographs from inside the Towers of Silence, where the Parsi community in Mumbai disposes of its dead. These forbidden photographs are creating big ripples in the small community. This is from an old CNN report. Dunn had hired a photographer to sneak into the towers of silence and capture images of the decomposing bodies.
那时没有足够的阳光让太阳能电池板真正发挥作用。丹想告诉人们，他们已故的亲人正在缓慢腐烂，他们的灵魂没有得到自由。这是来自寂静之塔内部的照片，孟买的帕西社区在这里处理死者。这些被禁止的照片在小社区中引起了巨大的涟漪。这是来自CNN的一篇旧报道。丹雇了一名摄影师潜入寂静之塔，拍摄了遗体腐烂的照片。
65-year-old Dhan Barya consigned her mother to the towers almost a year ago. So she was shocked to hear from insiders that the body was still rotting slowly. Years earlier, photos had been taken from a far-away telescopic lens and sent privately to Dinshah and the rest of the panchayat. This time, though, Dunn wanted to get photos from up close, and she wanted to go public with them. Everything was about to go up a notch. Awful images made the rounds, on flyers slipped under doors and into mailboxes.
65岁的丹·巴里亚在近一年前将母亲送进了塔中。所以当她从内部人士那里听说遗体仍在缓慢腐烂时，她感到震惊。几年前，有人用远距离望远镜头拍摄了照片，并私下寄给了丁沙（Dinshah）和潘查亚特的其他人。但这一次，丹想近距离拍摄照片，并想公开这些照片。一切都即将升级。可怕的照片四处流传，被塞在门下和邮箱里。
A 15-minute video circulating online showed bodies in various stages of decomposition. Images of loved ones with their eyes hollowed out, their mouths gaping at the sky. In the news clip, Dunn goes on to say, in Hindi, I'm not scared. I'm ready to fight. And just as I imagine Dhan might have predicted, what she did was met with a lot of anger. Not only at her claims,
一段在网上流传的15分钟视频显示了处于不同腐烂阶段的遗体。照片中，亲人的眼睛凹陷，嘴巴对着天空张开。在新闻片段中，丹用印地语说：“我不怕。我准备好战斗了。”正如我猜想丹可能预料到的那样，她的行为遭到了很多愤怒。不仅是因为她的主张，
but also that she broke into a sacred area, took photos and videos and spread them far and wide. Their anger extended to Dinshah Tamboli too, who was on the board of the Bombay Parsi Panchayat at the time. People wanted to ostracize us, that we are renegades, we are down, we are out to destroy the religion, etc. Dhan Badia's actions became the inflection point in a decades-long friction that had been building internally within the community.
还因为她闯入了一个神圣的区域，拍摄了照片和视频，并广泛传播。他们的愤怒也延伸到了当时在孟买帕西潘查亚特董事会的丁沙·坦博利（Dinshah Tamboli）身上。人们想排斥我们，说我们是叛徒，我们是堕落者，我们一心要摧毁宗教等等。丹·巴里亚的行为成为了社区内部几十年来不断积累的摩擦的转折点。
In response to Dhan's protest, Dinshah urged the rest of the panchayat to build an electric crematorium within Dungarvati. But the high priests decided instead to ban anyone who chose alternate methods from receiving prayers at all. When this controversy started and people started taking to cremation, the high priests of Bombay passed an edict. No prayer should be performed for those who get consigned to alternate methods, burial or lay. So people were feeling very upset about that. So people were feeling very upset about that. Then, in 2009, the panchayat discovered that two Parsi priests had been offering funerary rituals
为了回应丹的抗议，丁沙敦促潘查亚特的其他成员在邓加瓦迪内建造一个电动火葬场。但大祭司们决定禁止任何选择替代方法的人接受祈祷。当这场争议开始，人们开始转向火葬时，孟买的大祭司们发布了一项法令。对于那些被送去进行替代方法（土葬或火葬）的人，不应进行任何祈祷。所以人们对此感到非常不安。所以人们对此感到非常不安。然后，在2009年，潘查亚特发现两名帕西祭司一直在为一些秘密选择火葬的帕西人提供葬礼仪式。
to some Parsis who had secretly opted for cremation. They tried to ban those priests. It was a conflict that made its way all the way up to the Supreme Court. made its way all the way up to the Supreme Court. Dunn passed away in 2022. I found an obituary about her that described her as a quote, firebrand with low tolerance for fools and liars.
他们试图禁止这些祭司。这是一场一直闹到最高法院的冲突。一直闹到最高法院。丹于2022年去世。我找到了一篇关于她的讣告，称她为“一个对傻瓜和骗子零容忍的煽动者”。
Some parcies used Dunn's claims to continue advocating for burial and cremation to be considered religiously okay. They wanted to push past the bounds set by the orthodoxy. And then there were others, people who thought her accusations were completely made up. The photographs were doctored. This was doctored.
一些帕西人利用丹的主张继续倡导将土葬和火葬视为宗教上可接受的行为。他们想突破正统派设定的界限。还有一些人认为她的指控完全是捏造的。照片是伪造的。这是伪造的。
This is Khojeste Mistry again, Zoroastrian religious scholar and former trustee of the Bombay Parsi Panchayat, the council for the Parsi community in Mumbai. Khojeste and many other traditionalists want, desperately, to preserve Zoroastrian ritual in its purest form. So cremation is an absolute no-no as far as Zoroastrianism is concerned. You would be foolish to say I don't want to take the Tower of Silence route. I mean, you'd have to have your brains examined. I'm sorry to be so brutal and honest with you, but that's
这是霍杰斯特·米斯特里（Khojeste Mistry），琐罗亚斯德教宗教学者，也是孟买帕西潘查亚特的前受托人。霍杰斯特和许多其他传统主义者拼命想要以最纯粹的形式保护琐罗亚斯德教的仪式。因此，就琐罗亚斯德教而言，火葬是绝对禁止的。如果你说“我不想走寂静之塔这条路”，那你就是傻瓜。我很抱歉对你如此直率和诚实，但这就是
exactly the truth. At times during our conversations, it felt a little like I was speaking to a lawyer representing his client, the Towers of Silence. For Khojaste, it all started back when he was a student and on a trip to Iran. He had heard of a story about a mysterious Zoroastrian man who lived in the mountains there, close to a village called Cham. I was very keen to meet that man. I went to the village where this man used to occasionally appear, and his name was Mawbed Hormuzd. Khojaste said to the man, you seem so wise.
事实。有时在我们的谈话中，感觉就像我在和一个代表他的客户——寂静之塔——的律师交谈。对于霍杰斯特来说，这一切始于他还是学生时去伊朗的一次旅行。他听说过一个故事，关于一个住在那里山里、靠近一个叫查姆（Cham）村庄的神秘琐罗亚斯德教男子。“我非常渴望见到那个人。我去了那个男子偶尔出现的地方，他的名字叫莫贝德·霍尔穆兹（Mawbed Hormuzd）。”霍杰斯特对那个人说：“你看起来很有智慧。”
Please, tell me what I need to know about our religion." And he said, Khojaste, your job has to be to look after the Tower of Silence. Khojaste was studying to become a chartered accountant at the time, but this man was telling him that he needed to drop everything, go to Mumbai, and protect the towers there. I remember being angry with him and saying, tell me about things that are relevant for the living, not the dead. As an 18, 19 year old, I didn't want to know what you have to do with the Tower of Silence because I'd never ever been to a funeral at that point.
“请告诉我关于我们宗教我需要知道的事情。”他说：“霍杰斯特，你的工作必须是照顾寂静之塔。”霍杰斯特当时正在学习成为一名特许会计师，但这个人告诉他，他需要放弃一切，去孟买，保护那里的塔。我记得当时对他很生气，说：“告诉我与生者有关的事情，而不是死者。”作为一个18、19岁的年轻人，我不想知道你必须和寂静之塔有什么关系，因为那时我从来没有参加过葬礼。
I'd never ever lived in Bombay at that point either. I was a Poonaboy. So as far as the Towers of silence were concerned, it was alien to me. But decades later, in the early 80s, Khojeste moved to Mumbai. And over the years, Khojeste watched the happenings at Dungarvadi closely. He heard about Diklofenak and the fact that the vultures were mostly gone. He heard about the complaints, the subsequent experiments at the towers, Dunn's photos and the shame it brought to the community. And he heard the cries for a Parsi crematorium. The panchayat then got into a very awkward situation that the movers and shakers of the
那时我也从来没有住在孟买。我是个普纳男孩。所以就寂静之塔而言，它对我来说是陌生的。但几十年后，在80年代初，霍杰斯特搬到了孟买。多年来，霍杰斯特密切关注着邓加瓦迪发生的事情。他听说了双氯芬酸（Diclofenac），以及秃鹫几乎消失的事实。他听说了投诉、随后在塔上进行的实验、丹的照片以及它给社区带来的耻辱。他还听到了对帕西火葬场的呼声。潘查亚特随后陷入了一个非常尴尬的境地，因为社区的推动者和决策者
community wanted a crematorium in Dungarwadi, where we have our towers of sands, all pushing for stopping the tower of sands mode of disposal because the vultures had disappeared. There were no vultures. By this time, these towers or dakhmas had been banned in Iran. Sky burials had been declared a health hazard there in the 1970s. Without other options, most serastrians outside of India get buried or cremated.
想要在邓加瓦迪建立一个火葬场，我们有我们的寂静之塔，所有人都推动停止寂静之塔的处置方式，因为秃鹫已经消失了。没有秃鹫了。到这个时候，这些塔或达克玛（dakhmas）在伊朗已经被禁止了。天葬在20世纪70年代在那里被宣布为健康危害。由于没有其他选择，印度以外的大多数琐罗亚斯德教徒都被土葬或火葬。
And that's when I slowly had to jump in and start talking about the dakmas, having to take interest in vultures, and that's how my vulture story began. At this point, it seemed like there was widespread acceptance that the birds were gone interest in vultures. And that's how my vulture story began. At this point, it seemed like there was widespread acceptance that the birds were gone and not coming back. But Khojeste was like, no. The vultures have to come back. They simply have to.
也就是在那时，我不得不慢慢介入，开始谈论达克玛，不得不对秃鹫产生兴趣，这就是我的秃鹫故事的开始。在这一点上，似乎人们普遍接受了鸟类已经消失且不会回来的事实。但霍杰斯特说：“不。秃鹫必须回来。它们必须回来。”
Because I felt that this was an excellent system that had to be preserved, despite all the sort of negative publicity that began to germinate because the vultures had disappeared. Khojesty set his eyes on a specific mission, to turn the Mumbai Towers of Silence into a giant vulture aviary. The idea was, let's bring the vultures back to feed on parsee dead, but protect them in an enclosure, away from diclofenac and any other drugs that would kill them. So shortly after Dunn made those photos public, Kogeste got to work.
因为我觉得这是一个必须保留的优秀系统，尽管由于秃鹫的消失，开始出现各种负面宣传。霍杰斯特设定了一个特定的使命，将孟买的寂静之塔变成一个巨大的秃鹫鸟舍。这个想法是，让我们把秃鹫带回来以食取帕西死者，但把它们保护在一个围栏里，远离双氯芬酸和任何其他会杀死它们的药物。所以就在丹公开那些照片后不久，霍杰斯特就开始行动了。
Kogeste has a beautiful voice, a very loud voice. This is raptor breeder and conservationist Jemima Perry-Jones. Jemima runs the oldest breeding center for birds of prey in the world. So naturally, Kogeste went to the UK to meet her. Jemima described to me the first time she met Kogeste at the cafe of her breeding center in the UK. And you could have heard a pin drop in my cafe, literally. Because people like me, you know, we haven't had people come and sit down and say, well, the vultures aren't coming in to eat our dead and the kites are coming in and they're
霍杰斯特有一个美妙的声音，一个非常响亮的声音。这是猛禽饲养员和保护主义者杰米玛·佩里-琼斯（Jemima Perry-Jones）。杰米玛经营着世界上最古老的猛禽繁殖中心。所以自然地，霍杰斯特去了英国见她。杰米玛向我描述了她第一次在英国她繁殖中心的咖啡馆见到霍杰斯特的情景。“在我的咖啡馆里，你甚至能听到针掉在地上的声音，真的。因为像我这样的人，你知道，我们没有见过有人坐下来，说，好吧，秃鹫不来吃我们的死者，而鸢（kites）却进来了，它们在
picking up bits of our dead and then they're flying out of Mumbai and they're dropping them on people and people don't like it. You know, it's an extraordinary conversation. Khojeste was there to ask Jemima for advice. What would it take to bring the vultures back and to house them at the Towers of Silence? The problem was there wasn't really an answer that they wanted that I could give them. Because their idea was you could just put a big net over the top of each of the towers and lob in some vultures and it would be fine.
捡拾我们死者的碎片，然后它们飞出孟买，把它们扔在人们身上，人们不喜欢这样。你知道，这是一次非同寻常的谈话。”霍杰斯特在那里是为了向杰米玛寻求建议。把秃鹫带回来并把它们安置在寂静之塔需要什么？问题是，我无法给出他们想要的答案。因为他们的想法是，你可以在每座塔的顶部放一个大网，然后扔进一些秃鹫，一切都会好起来的。
And you couldn't do that. Jemima was like, it's gonna be much more complicated than that. So I designed an aviary with the towers within the aviary that would have worked, possibly. Jemima's proposal outlines some specific criteria. She said to Kogeste, you need to supplement the human food with enough additional meat, probably goat. You'd have to create places for the vultures to bathe. It'd need to be a huge aviary.
你不能那样做。杰米玛说：“这会比那复杂得多。”所以我设计了一个鸟舍，塔就在鸟舍内，这可能行得通。杰米玛的提案概述了一些具体的标准。她对霍杰斯特说，你需要用足够的额外肉类（可能是山羊肉）来补充人类食物。你必须为秃鹫创造洗澡的地方。那需要一个巨大的鸟舍。
You'd have to clean the aviaries, which would have been a nightmare because if you upset the vultures, they have a habit of vomiting. And you know, you don't really want them vomiting up somebody's grandmother in front of you. So there were all sorts of things that made it a very difficult proposition. Without a clear consensus on the aviary plan, Kogestey then ran for a seat on the Bombay-Parsi panchayat and got elected in 2008. Now he was in charge of all things theukhmanishini, the same position that Dinshaw had been in a decade before. This time, in 2010, Khojeste got a swanky architecture studio to make a 3D model of a vulture aviary at Tungarvadi. A geometric structure of tension cables and netting supported by columns. The photos are online and they're honestly kind of beautiful.
你必须清理鸟舍，那将是一场噩梦，因为如果你惹恼了秃鹫，它们有呕吐的习惯。你知道，你真的不想看到它们在你面前呕吐出某人的祖母。所以有各种各样的事情使它成为一个非常困难的提议。由于在鸟舍计划上没有达成明确共识，霍杰斯特随后竞选孟买帕西潘查亚特的席位，并于2008年当选。现在他负责所有关于“塔”的事情，这与十年前丁沙的职位相同。这一次，在2010年，霍杰斯特找了一个时髦的建筑工作室，制作了一个邓加瓦迪秃鹫鸟舍的3D模型。一个由柱子支撑的张力电缆和网状结构的几何结构。照片在网上，老实说它们很漂亮。
The idea for an aviary, it turned into a whole thing. There were countless meetings, news articles and presentations about it over several decades. But ultimately it has remained simply an idea. At one point, 19 Parsi physicians signed a letter of concern about the aviary project because the painkiller diclofenac was and still is administered to humans and especially to end-of-life patients. There's no way a doctor can guarantee that when somebody dies they are diclofenac free.
关于鸟舍的想法，它变成了一件大事。几十年来，关于它有无数次的会议、新闻文章和演讲。但最终它仅仅停留在一个想法上。有一次，19名帕西医生签署了一封关于鸟舍项目的担忧信，因为止痛药双氯芬酸过去和现在仍然被用于人类，特别是临终病人。医生不可能保证某人去世时体内没有双氯芬酸。
That's journalist Mira Subramanian again. You know somebody could be taking diclofenac for planter's warts and then have a heart attack. Like there's just no way to make sure that the human bodies would be safe. Diclofenac is literally in thousands of pharmaceutical formulations. It's really hard to isolate. If diclofenac was in a Parsi person's bloodstream, the already endangered vultures in the aviary would just die. Just like before. And with four more drugs on the market today that have been tested to be just as killer to gyps vultures, the panchayat's plan was met with
那是记者米拉·苏布拉马尼安（Mira Subramanian）再次提到。你知道，有人可能因为跖疣而服用双氯芬酸，然后心脏病发作。根本没有办法确保人类遗体是安全的。双氯芬酸实际上存在于数千种药物配方中。它真的很难分离。如果双氯芬酸在帕西人的血液中，鸟舍里本已濒临灭绝的秃鹫就会死去。就像以前一样。而且今天市场上还有四种药物被测试证明对白背秃鹫同样具有杀伤力，潘查亚特的计划遭到了
a good deal of apprehension. All this made it hard to reach consensus on the aviary project. So ultimately, Khojaste's plan fizzled out. The aviary project died a natural death. How does it feel to have tried so hard and the vultures are not back? My time to go to Dungarwadi is also coming round. You know, you begin to think about mortality as you get older. Lasha, it's certainly something one thinks about. Now, as far as I'm concerned, when I die, certainly I'll be able to meet Mavud Hormuz upstairs in the spiritual world and say, I did my best.
相当多的忧虑。所有这些使得在鸟舍项目上达成共识变得困难。所以最终，霍杰斯特的计划不了了之。鸟舍项目自然死亡了。尝试了这么多，秃鹫却没有回来，感觉如何？“我去邓加瓦迪的时间也快到了。你知道，当你变老时，你会开始思考死亡。拉沙，这当然是人们会思考的事情。现在，就我而言，当我去世时，我肯定能在精神世界里见到莫贝德·霍尔穆兹，并说，我已经尽力了。”
most upstairs in the spiritual world and say, I did my best. Despite the very obvious logistical barriers, every couple years, it seems that the idea for an aviary resurfaces with new fervor. The latest article is from just a few months ago, January 2024, announcing a new plan to build a vulture aviary atop the towers. This time though, it's not Kogeste spearheading. His time on the Panchayat ended almost a decade ago. A few months ago, I traveled with Dinshaw to a Dungarwadi in another town,
“在精神世界里见到莫贝德·霍尔穆兹，并说，我已经尽力了。”尽管存在非常明显的后勤障碍，但似乎每隔几年，关于鸟舍的想法就会以新的热情重新浮出水面。最近的一篇文章就在几个月前，即2024年1月，宣布了一项在塔顶建造秃鹫鸟舍的新计划。不过这一次，不是霍杰斯特在牵头。他在潘查亚特的时间几乎在十年前就结束了。几个月前，我和丁沙一起去了另一个城镇的邓加瓦迪，
far from the tension that's mostly centered around the main Dungarwadi in Mumbai. It was lush and peaceful. I was allowed to approach the base of one of the towers, and when I craned my neck, I could see one of the solar panels hovering above the rim, held up by what looked like a long telephone pole. Despite the fact that Dunn exposed the shortcomings of the solar concentrators, this is the method still in use atop the towers today. The solar panels were small and uninspiring, nothing like what I'd imagined. Most of all,
远离主要集中在孟买邓加瓦迪的紧张局势。那里郁郁葱葱，宁静祥和。我被允许靠近其中一座塔的底部，当我伸长脖子时，我可以看到其中一块太阳能电池板悬浮在边缘上方，由看起来像一根长电话杆的东西支撑着。尽管丹揭露了太阳能聚光器的缺点，但这仍然是今天塔顶使用的方法。太阳能电池板很小，平淡无奇，和我想象的完全不同。最重要的是，
they were broken. The mirrored glass was completely shattered, leaving the panels useless. There was this amazing moment when I saw the culprit, a peacock, flying up to the one intact mirror and pecking at the glass. Oh my god, wow. Yeah. Wow, so they really do climb up to the towers. That's amazing. Wow. Okay, so there's a peacock and it climbed onto the solar panel right in front of us. It's looking at its reflection and pecking its beak into the glass. Have you heard of the Mumbai Dungawadi ever having a peacock problem? Plenty.
它们坏了。镜面玻璃完全破碎，使电池板毫无用处。有一个令人惊叹的时刻，我看到了罪魁祸首，一只孔雀，飞到那面完好的镜子上，啄着玻璃。“天哪，哇。”“是的。”“哇，它们真的会爬到塔上。太神奇了。”“哇。好吧，所以有一只孔雀，它爬到了我们面前的太阳能电池板上。它看着自己的倒影，用喙啄着玻璃。你听说过孟买邓加瓦迪有孔雀问题吗？”“很多。”
Yeah? Plenty. Yeah? Plenty. Imagine putting so much effort into finding a solution, only to have a different type of bird come in and mess it up. The solar panels had once felt like a viable alternative to dispose of the dead in the absence of vultures. But now you have peacocks pecking at the remains of this failed experiment. And for corpse bearers, who already face precarious labor conditions and low wages, they sometimes
“是吗？很多。”“是吗？很多。”想象一下，投入了这么多努力去寻找解决方案，结果却有另一种鸟进来把它搞砸了。太阳能电池板曾经感觉像是秃鹫缺席时处理死者的可行替代方案。但现在你有孔雀在啄食这个失败实验的残骸。对于抬棺人来说，他们已经面临不稳定的劳动条件和低工资，他们有时
need to drag a body around multiple times to keep relocating the solar panels on different body parts in order for the corpse to fully decompose. Corpse bearers in Mumbai unionized in 2003, and every so often, rumors spread about a strike. As Dinshaw and I continued on through the Dungarwadi, we walked the perimeter of one of the towers. Our guide told us that about 35 bodies were currently up there. of one of the towers. Our guide told us that about 35 bodies were currently up there. I could smell a distinct rotting
需要多次拖动遗体，以便在不同的身体部位重新定位太阳能电池板，从而使遗体完全分解。孟买的抬棺人在2003年成立了工会，每隔一段时间，就会有关于罢工的传言。当丁沙和我继续穿过邓加瓦迪时，我们沿着其中一座塔的周边走。我们的向导告诉我们，目前上面大约有35具遗体。我们的向导告诉我们，目前上面大约有35具遗体。我能闻到一种明显的腐烂味
as I walked the circumference of this tower. But if I willed myself to believe it was fresh compost I was smelling, I probably could. A couple days later, I brought this observation up to Kogeste. Just because people have the issue of smell, do you stop an entire system which supports a forest? Do you change the religion and religious practices just because of smell?
当我沿着这座塔的圆周走时。但如果我强迫自己相信我闻到的是新鲜的堆肥，我可能也能做到。几天后，我向霍杰斯特提到了这个观察结果。“仅仅因为人们有气味的问题，你就停止支持森林的整个系统吗？你仅仅因为气味就改变宗教和宗教习俗吗？”
Kogeste thinks that focusing on smell is misguided, but there is something he feels increasingly concerned about. We have a problem now, high rise buildings coming up around Tungarwadi. The scale of development that Mumbai has seen in the last few decades is colossal. Back when Dinshwar Tamboli received that threatening letter from overlooking neighbors of Tungarwadi, there were only two high rises in the area. Kodjaste told me that back then, even his home, where I met him, was once Dungarwadi land before it turned into a housing complex.
霍杰斯特认为关注气味是被误导的，但他确实对某件事感到越来越担忧。“我们现在有一个问题，邓加瓦迪周围正在兴起高层建筑。孟买在过去几十年里看到的开发规模是巨大的。”当丁沙·坦博利收到那封来自邓加瓦迪俯瞰邻居的威胁信时，该地区只有两座高层建筑。霍杰斯特告诉我，那时，甚至他住的房子，我见到他的地方，在变成住宅区之前也曾是邓加瓦迪的土地。
Till 123 years ago, Panthers were roaming around where you're sitting today. This is part of Dungarwadi land where this building has come up. But today, the Dungarwadi neighborhood looks like a forest of skyscrapers surrounding the actual forest. Next to the Dungarwadi's main arched entrance way, a tall billboard advertises the modern comforts of life. Cars, handbags, life insurance. The industrial clang of luxury apartment construction is constant. All the time. This road, I think at the moment there might be no less than 10 new projects. So possibly, you know, 20-30 buildings coming up. And presumably there are going to be high rises. All will be high rises because this being one of the poshest areas
“直到123年前，豹子还在你今天坐的地方周围游荡。这是邓加瓦迪土地的一部分，这栋建筑就是在这里建起来的。”但今天，邓加瓦迪社区看起来就像环绕着实际森林的摩天大楼森林。在邓加瓦迪主要的拱形入口旁边，一块高大的广告牌宣传着现代生活的舒适。汽车、手提包、人寿保险。豪华公寓建设的工业叮当声是持续不断的。“一直都是。这条路，我想目前可能有不少于10个新项目。所以可能，你知道，有20-30栋建筑正在兴起。而且大概都会是高层建筑。所有这些都将是高层建筑，因为这里是孟买最昂贵的地区之一，
of Mumbai, Malabar Hill, it is just going to be super expensive, multi-storeyed buildings, and all of them are going to be overlooking Dungarwadi. That's Rashne Pardhiwala again. At the moment we've got possibly seven buildings overlooking. I think in the next 10 years we will just be surrounded, 360 degrees, we will be surrounded by tall towers. As an ecologist, Rashne has been planting trees around the circumference of each tower. Trees like bamboo that grow tall and fast, and can obscure the view from surrounding buildings. But as Khojeste once told me, Lasha, the bottom line is that, as I now know, the vultures are ancillary to the system.
马拉巴尔山（Malabar Hill），它将变得超级昂贵，多层建筑，而且所有这些都将俯瞰邓加瓦迪。”那是拉什内·帕迪瓦拉（Rashne Pardhiwala）再次提到。目前我们可能有七栋建筑俯瞰。我想在未来10年内，我们将被包围，360度，我们将被高塔包围。作为一名生态学家，拉什内一直在每座塔的周边种植树木。像竹子这样长得又高又快的树，可以遮挡周围建筑的视线。但正如霍杰斯特曾经告诉我的，“拉沙，底线是，正如我现在所知，秃鹫是系统的辅助。”
The most important is the sun. With the absence of vultures, the sun is the only thing that can break down the bodies of deceased Parsi's. But the taller these apartment buildings rise, and then in turn, the taller these trees buildings rise, and then in turn the taller these trees that are meant to obstruct their views rise, it also means that it'll be harder for the sun's rays to reach the bodies atop the towers. And really, at this point, sunlight
“最重要的是太阳。在没有秃鹫的情况下，太阳是唯一能分解已故帕西人遗体的东西。”但这些公寓楼建得越高，反过来，这些旨在阻挡它们视线的树木长得越高，这也意味着太阳光线将更难到达塔顶的遗体。而且真的，在这一点上，阳光
is all there is that's left to decompose these bodies. The whole forest is going to be in darkness and in shadow. Is that going to serve the purpose? That's going to be counterproductive to the Rukmishai system. So these are tough, tough challenges. In 2015, a Parsi crematorium was finally established in Mumbai, though not inside the Dungarwadi. And Dinshaw Temboli, former member of the Bombay Parsi Panchayat, was one of the key people behind setting it up. Some Parsis are afraid that if cremation and burial grow in popularity and fewer and fewer people take to the towers and in the face of encroaching development,
是唯一剩下的分解这些遗体的东西。整个森林都将处于黑暗和阴影中。这能达到目的吗？这对鲁克米沙（Rukmishai）系统来说将适得其反。所以这些是艰难的、艰难的挑战。2015年，孟买终于建立了一个帕西火葬场，尽管不在邓加瓦迪内。而前孟买帕西潘查亚特成员丁沙·坦博利是建立它的关键人物之一。一些帕西人担心，如果火葬和土葬越来越受欢迎，越来越多的人不再选择塔，而且面对不断侵蚀的开发，
that the Dungarwadi land might be taken away from them. So once we have buildings surrounding us, 360 degrees, what is going to be the solution? Right now, one person is complaining, tomorrow 10 people will complain. Tomorrow, if we've got thousands of residents complaining to the municipal corporation, the municipal corporation is going to be forced
邓加瓦迪的土地可能会被夺走。“所以一旦我们周围有建筑，360度，解决方案会是什么？现在，一个人在抱怨，明天10个人会抱怨。明天，如果我们有成千上万的居民向市政公司投诉，市政公司将被迫
to address the issue. And then are they going to really weigh the religious sentiments of a community up against an entire larger community that might take objection? With real estate in Malabar Hill priced around $800 per square foot, the Dungarwadi could be worth about $2 billion. But the Parsi's own this land.
解决这个问题。然后他们真的会权衡一个社区的宗教情感与整个可能提出反对的更大社区吗？”马拉巴尔山的房地产价格约为每平方英尺800美元，邓加瓦迪的价值可能约为20亿美元。但帕西人拥有这片土地。
It belongs to them. So I had to ask Rashne to lay out more clearly why there seems to be this vague but collective fear of the land being taken away from them. Okay, so let me answer the question this way. vague but collective fear of the land being taken away from them. Okay, so let me answer the question this way. As the Parsi community has dwindled, as the numbers have fallen, we have seen in other parts of India where, because there is no Parsi population, the local Parsi panchayat has been forced to sell
它属于他们。所以我不得不请拉什内更清楚地说明，为什么似乎存在这种模糊但集体的土地被夺走的恐惧。“好吧，让我这样回答这个问题。模糊但集体的土地被夺走的恐惧。好吧，让我这样回答这个问题。随着帕西社区的萎缩，随着人数的减少，我们在印度其他地方看到，因为没有帕西人口，当地的帕西潘查亚特被迫出售
the land because there are no Parsis. And that's happened across India. And so if there are no Parsis left, the land will be taken over by the government. This is something Rashne has seen herself. On a recent work trip, she visited a city called Jalna, which used to have a big Parsi community. When I visited Jalna, there hadn't been a single Parsi in Jalna for the past 37 years.
土地，因为没有帕西人了。这种情况在印度各地都发生过。所以如果没有帕西人留下，土地将被政府接管。”这是拉什内亲眼所见的事情。在最近的一次工作旅行中，她访问了一个叫贾尔纳（Jalna）的城市，那里曾经有一个很大的帕西社区。当我访问贾尔纳时，过去37年里贾尔纳没有一个帕西人。
The whole Parsi population had been white-clad. Not only were there no Parsis left, but there was also no functioning Dungarwadi. What used to be the Dungarwadi is now government land. When I went there, he showed me a dhokma saying, I asked him, what's that? He said, a well. I said, what well? No, somebody said it's a well. I said, it's not a well, it's a dhokma. And the locals said, oh, we don't know what that is. The towers and their sacred role, it had all been forgotten. I had seen this too. In a different town, I visited an abandoned dungarvadi with a couple defunct towers of silence.
整个帕西人口都已消失。不仅没有帕西人留下，也没有运作中的邓加瓦迪。曾经是邓加瓦迪的地方现在是政府土地。当我到那里时，他指着一个达克玛说，我问他，那是什么？他说，一口井。我说，什么井？不，有人说是井。我说，那不是井，那是达克玛。当地人说，哦，我们不知道那是什么。塔及其神圣的作用，这一切都被遗忘了。我也见过这种情况。在另一个城镇，我参观了一个废弃的邓加瓦迪，有几座废弃的寂静之塔。
Due to the population loss of Parsis, there were no more priests left to administer the death rituals. So the panchayat in that town started leasing the land to non-Parsi farmers. They had been using one of the empty dakmas to store a giant pile of castor oil seeds. One other abandoned tower had a large solar panel above it, creating solar energy to irrigate the land for sandalwood farming. All this on what used to be a sacred Dungravadi forest. They were using solar panels, but not to desiccate Parsi remains. There's a very real fear that one day,
由于帕西人口的流失，没有祭司来主持死亡仪式。所以那个城镇的潘查亚特开始把土地租给非帕西农民。他们一直在使用其中一个空达克玛来储存一大堆蓖麻油种子。另一座废弃的塔上方有一块巨大的太阳能电池板，产生太阳能来灌溉檀香种植园的土地。所有这些都在曾经是神圣的邓加瓦迪森林上。他们在使用太阳能电池板，但不是为了使帕西遗体脱水。有一种非常真实的恐惧，有一天，
the Parsis will completely fade into memory alongside the vultures. It is scary though, like how quickly we forget things. Already there's been a whole generation that has never seen a vulture, you know? And so it's just this thing that, you know, Tata and Bhatti talk about, but it's not something you've ever seen. And so it becomes, it becomes mythology.
帕西人将和秃鹫一起完全消失在记忆中。这很可怕，你知道，我们忘记事情的速度有多快。已经有一整代人从未见过秃鹫，你知道吗？所以这只是塔塔（Tata）和巴蒂（Bhatti）谈论的事情，但这不是你见过的事情。所以它变成了，它变成了神话。
As a species, the vultures were here first. They've lived here for millions of years, long before humans and their ideas of religion and ritual came into being. And there's a chance that vultures might have outlived us humans entirely, had we not been so competent at devastating our planet. Conservationists in India started breeding these endangered vultures in captivity in 2004, but these vultures and their keepers alike are in waiting. They're waiting for safer skies.
作为一个物种，秃鹫先来到这里。它们在这里生活了数百万年，远在人类及其宗教和仪式观念产生之前。如果不是我们如此擅长破坏我们的星球，秃鹫可能早就比我们人类活得更久了。印度的保护主义者在2004年开始在圈养中繁殖这些濒危秃鹫，但这些秃鹫和它们的饲养员都在等待。他们在等待更安全的天空。
They're waiting for the government to ban all vulture toxic drugs from use, waiting for farmers to get used to using vulture safe alternatives. The possibility of seeing vultures return to the open skies again in huge numbers, it's all part of the dream, but it's going to take a lot of time. The biology of a vulture is just, it's just, they work on deep time. Vultures only lay one egg a year, which is a terrible evolutionary strategy. But on top of that, they then raise that chick for about 60 days, and then it sits unable to fly for four more months. It's just a long, slow process.
他们在等待政府禁止所有秃鹫有毒药物的使用，等待农民习惯使用秃鹫安全的替代品。再次看到秃鹫成群结队地回到开阔天空的可能性，这都是梦想的一部分，但这需要很长时间。秃鹫的生物学特性就是，它们在深层时间上运作。秃鹫一年只产一个蛋，这是一种糟糕的进化策略。但最重要的是，它们还要抚养那只雏鸟约60天，然后它还要再坐四个月才能飞行。这是一个漫长而缓慢的过程。
And so their numbers could come back, and that's only after all of these drugs go away. But it could take a very, very long time. It's my last day here in Mumbai, and I'm having breakfast at my hotel. This hotel, by the way, yet another development from which one could peer down into the towers. A moment ago, I caught myself looking up at the sky, and I saw what I think was a single black kite flying past a neighboring high rise. I'm trying to imagine what vultures must have looked like
所以它们的数量可能会回来，那也只有在所有这些药物消失之后。但这可能需要非常、非常长的时间。这是我在孟买的最后一天，我正在酒店吃早餐。顺便说一句，这家酒店是另一个开发项目，从那里可以俯瞰塔楼。刚才，我发现自己抬头看着天空，我看到了一只我认为是黑鸢的鸟飞过邻近的高层建筑。我试图想象秃鹫看起来是什么样子
in huge numbers up here, in this sky right above Dungarwadi. I'm an atheist, but I was raised Hindu. And in my family, all of our dead have followed a very specific tradition. Bodies are placed on an open-aired wooden pyre and consumed by flames. family, all of our dead have followed a very specific tradition. Bodies are placed on an open-aired wooden pyre and consumed by flames. Then, the remaining bones and ashes are tossed into River Ganga, or the Ganges River. For Hindus, it's one of the most sacred places on Earth.
成群结队地在这里，在邓加瓦迪上方的这片天空中。我是无神论者，但我是在印度教家庭长大的。在我的家庭中，我们所有的死者都遵循一个非常具体的传统。遗体被放置在露天的木柴堆上，被火焰吞噬。家庭中，我们所有的死者都遵循一个非常具体的传统。遗体被放置在露天的木柴堆上，被火焰吞噬。然后，剩下的骨头和骨灰被扔进恒河（River Ganga），或恒河（Ganges River）。对于印度教徒来说，这是地球上最神圣的地方之一。
But it's also one of the most polluted. This river is a place where people bathe, where carcasses and bodies are deposited, and where almost half a billion people get their drinking water. I've had a hard time reckoning with the idea that the river that's thought to spiritually cleanse our souls is so overrun with toxic waste and sewage, and yet all four of my grandparents' remains have been sent off into Ganga.
但它也是污染最严重的地方之一。这条河是人们沐浴、倾倒尸体和遗体的地方，也是近五亿人获取饮用水的地方。我很难接受这样一个想法：被认为在精神上净化我们灵魂的河流竟然充斥着有毒废物和污水，然而我所有四位祖父母的遗体都被送进了恒河。
I think when we stop being able to die together, in the way our ancestors did, we risk coming apart as a people. Keeping to tradition is part of what makes it all tolerable. Death, I mean, and the grief that comes with it. And sometimes, in the face of something that threatens those inherited ways, all we can do is find something to hold on to. And so, I think of Roshne, how she told me that every so often, she'll meet a Parsi who will ask her to plant specific trees inside Dungarvadi, trees they remembered the vultures loved to roost on.
我想，当我们无法再像祖先那样一起死去时，我们就有可能作为一个民族分崩离析。坚持传统是让这一切变得可以忍受的一部分。我是说死亡，以及随之而来的悲伤。有时，面对威胁那些继承方式的事物，我们所能做的就是找到一些东西来坚持。所以，我想到了拉什内，她告诉我，每隔一段时间，她就会遇到一个帕西人，要求她在邓加瓦迪内种植特定的树木，他们记得秃鹫喜欢栖息在这些树上。
Don't forget the fishtail palm, they tell her, or the Pamyra. And so, Rashne started planting. This way, she tells me, if the vultures ever return, this forest will be ready to accept them. The End 99% Invisible was reported this week by Lash Madon and edited by Christopher Johnson. Lash's reporting was supported by the International Women's Media Foundation's Howard G. Buffett Fund for Women Journalists. Mixed by Martín González. Music by Swan Real and APM. Fact-checking by Graham Haysha.
“别忘了鱼尾葵（fishtail palm），”他们告诉她，“或者帕米拉棕榈（Pamyra）。”所以，拉什内开始种植。她告诉我，这样，如果秃鹫有一天回来，这片森林将准备好接受它们。结束。99% Invisible本周由拉沙·马多恩（Lash Madon）报道，克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）编辑。拉沙的报道得到了国际妇女媒体基金会（International Women's Media Foundation）霍华德·G·巴菲特妇女记者基金（Howard G. Buffett Fund for Women Journalists）的支持。马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martín González）混音。音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）和APM提供。事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙（Graham Haysha）完成。
Voice-over by Rashmi Ghanatra. A very, very special thanks to everyone featured in today's episode. Special thanks also to Divya Kowasji and Ayushi Shah for helping us with translation and reporting in Mumbai. And thanks to everyone who wasn't featured in this episode but who was integral to the reporting process including Dr. Percy Avari, Dr. Abhan Markar Kabraji, Ann Radamacher, Munir Varani, Chris Bowden, Homi Kushwulkan, Framroz Mirsa, Sharzad Pavri, Patokshi Rastamfram, Shapur Merolia, and Peter Ayres. Thank you so much. Kathy Tu is our Executive Producer, Kirk Colestead is the Digital Director, Delaney Hall is our
旁白由Rashmi Ghanatra担任。非常、非常感谢今天节目中出现的所有人。还要特别感谢Divya Kowasji和Ayushi Shah在孟买为我们提供的翻译和报道帮助。感谢所有未在节目中出现但对报道过程至关重要的人，包括Percy Avari医生、Abhan Markar Kabraji医生、Ann Radamacher、Munir Varani、Chris Bowden、Homi Kushwulkan、Framroz Mirsa、Sharzad Pavri、Patokshi Rastamfram、Shapur Merolia和Peter Ayres。非常感谢你们。Kathy Tu是我们的执行制片人，Kirk Colestead是数字总监，Delaney Hall是我们的
Senior Editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Ley, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Gladney, Kelly Prime, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Sarah Bake, Nina Potuck, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stephen Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California.
高级编辑。团队其他成员包括Chris Berube、Jason DeLeon、Emmett Fitzgerald、Vivian Ley、Joe Rosenberg、Gabriella Gladney、Kelly Prime、Jacob Maldonado-Medina、Sarah Bake、Nina Potuck，以及我，Roman Mars。99% Invisible的标志由Stephen Lawrence创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区外的Pandora大楼。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城区。
You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our new Discord server. I encourage you to talk to us there. Uptown, Oakland, California. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们新的Discord服务器上找到我们。我鼓励你在那里与我们交流。加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城区。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。